this this bush guy this George Bush
remember he was the president and now
his brother has jumped in Jeb Bush who
was the governor of Florida he may run
for president and he told matt lauer on
the today show so let's take a look at
the clip got that you're talking about
it sounds like you are gearing up for a
run those are the kinds of things people
do when they're increasing their public
profile are you going to run in 2016
this that's way off into the future I
have a voice I want to share my beliefs
about how the conservative movement and
the Republican Party can regain its
footing because we've lost our way but
you clearly have not ruled out you will
not definitively rule out a run for
president in the year 2016 I won't but
i'm not going to declare today either
method all right so there you have it we
may have another bush you know we had
one bush for four years then we had one
for eight years we've had the clinton we
may have another Clinton do people
remember that that's why we left England
a couple hundred years ago to like avoid
monarchies and families that just run
everything Gloria what do you think he's
running I mean it's very clear sitting
looking at him with those glasses on its
face he is running for president yeah he
it's very clear that that's what's
happening right now do we need another
bush do you think that maybe he could
clean up the mess of the first Bush no
one can clean up the messes of the
bushes it's just a gentle removal girl
can completely clean up there guys it's
the web so we can say whatever she just
threw a softball are you really doing
doctor thank you Osceola lately Darnley
allowed a certain grace period after one
election before we start in on another
one apparently not my xanax prescription
has already run out from the last from
the last election do I have to refill it
now already yeah as I gear up for this
one I can't take it i need i need at
least six months yeah before we get too
deep into this a new election yeah like
orders daily pause and everything's all
ready for next year in a break he is
running and he has a very good chance
really you think it is a good trick i do
i'm sorry i think that it's florida
number one and he's loved in florida he
also i mean he's going to grab a rubio
and they're gonna run
a bad horse that's what's happening
Ruby's going to drink a lot of water and
he's going to be ready to run for vice
president what do you guys think of this
idea that we we pick these families like
the bushes and the Clintons and we just
go time after time it's like this
endless brand like we like them like we
like you know coca-cola like oh you know
it so that's always what you get but
like isn't that creating just this class
that runs the show give me something
serious here I there's no way I can she
was a roomie well I to the vending
machine um no I mean you're I think
people are like comfortable things that
they know and you know even with the
bushes look you know I'm a Democrat but
even I have like a very small soft spot
for George W because he was like an
adorable little animal do you aim and
Jeb who and I'm a Florida native proud
to say it from born and raised in Miami
um you know he was like are like own
adorable Frankenstein who ruined things
but it was like Oh Frankie right now the
Clinton brand is so much stronger than
the mush Brandis yeah dad I think it's
no contest if this was gonna be the race
right now I think it would be a
landslide clearly for Hillary she's the
most powerful woman in the country the
most well-liked woman after our first
lady and you know I think people are
still stunned by what bush did to this
country so i don't know if that's gonna
be the contest i honestly don't think
it's gonna be a strong one I hope that's
the contest like if it is a jab and
Hillary then we're golden but I just
feel like I I definitely feel like he's
gonna run I think he's gonna grab Rubio
and I think it's gonna be a tough race I
on it I mean I know what is this like
three years three and a half years out I
mean right now but you know it's never
too soon Michelle we have three years to
talk about this and for you to go I want
to talk about the bachelor thank God I
know that's happening for three years
for this economy to improve and I really
do feel like at the end of Obama's
second term that this economy is gonna
look very different than it does now
yeah I think unemployment's gonna be way
down I think I think the Democrats are
going to be sort of on in a really good
spot yeah what do you think about the
way they brand all these people how like
we said it before we started that even
jeb Bush's glasses it was like you are
gonna be the smarter bush you know like
what do you think about this just
machine that builds these people
politics though I mean it's not just
picking somebody up off the street and
they're just gonna be the president of
the united states they have to be
groomed to do that yeah you know that's
just what it is and yet none of you were
wearing glasses here today have three
pairs of contact lenses yeah I like
extra are we sure that Matt Lauer's
classes were actually real and not a
prop they real lenses in there they may
well that is that's what I want to find
out get to the bottom doesn't last as I
wore when I like audition for the price
is right I was like look I look like
Drew they were like back row bonobos
calm is the official outfitter of the
Ruben report enter code Ruben report for
twenty percent off your next purchase